Trascrizione: Nicoletta Pedrana
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Ma voi l'avete mai vista,
una partita di calcio 100 contro 1?
Ora, in questo esperimento
folle giapponese,
100 erano bambini e 3 erano adulti:
ma nel mondo della cybersecurity,
della sicurezza informatica,
gli attaccanti sono 100
contro solo un difensore.
È una storia molto più impari,
un confronto assolutamente non alla pari.
La storia della cybersecurity,
della sicurezza informatica,
è una storia relativamente breve:
si parla degli ultimi
20, 30 anni al massimo.
La sua era d'oro, di fatto,
va ancora disegnata,
e probabilmente proprio
in questo decennio.
Ma il concetto di sicurezza
delle informazioni,
e sicurezza del dato,
è un concetto che di fatto è antico
come la storia dell'umanità.
Siamo evoluti da una fase
in cui si origliavano le conversazioni,
e si necessitava di essere
fisicamente prossimi
alla persona che andavamo ad origliare,
a una fase dopo,
in cui è stata inventata la scrittura,
e quindi si potevano
intercettare dei messaggi,
fino all'attuale capitalismo
della sorveglianza
dove teoricamente possiamo ascoltare
qualsiasi conversazione
dalla nostra stanza.
Quello che è cambiato,
nel corso della storia,
è il raggio della nostra
capacità di intercettare.
Il problema con la sicurezza informatica,
con la cybersecurity,
è che non riusciamo a visualizzarla:
il meglio che il fior fiore
del giornalismo occidentale,
che Hollywood,
sono riusciti a proporre
è questa immagine stereotipata
di un ragazzino brufoloso, nerd,
con felpa e cappuccio,
che dalla sua stanza,
smanettando sul computer,
riesce a entrare in tutti
i sistemi al mondo,
Quindi, se riusciamo a trovare noi
quel singolo ragazzino
abbiamo risolto tutti i problemi a livello
di sicurezza informatica al mondo.
Se vi interessa, invece,
capire un po' più nel dettaglio
cosa vuol dire seriamente cyber security,
provate a fare questo sforzo
di immaginazione.
Siete in Iran, è il 2008
e siete a capo del programma
di arricchimento nucleare del Paese.
Sedete nella vostra stanza,
avete tutti i vostri parametri
sotto controllo.
Eppure ogni mese, periodicamente,
il programma fallisce.
Nessuno riesce a spiegarsi
perché fallisce;
e c'è una ragione in realtà,
perché quello che è successo
veramente, nel 2008,
a Natanz, nella centrale
nucleare iraniana,
è che qualcuno si è
infiltrato nella centrale
e ha infettato, probabilmente
con una chiavetta USB,
i sistemi della centrale
in maniera tale da riuscire
a fare una singola cosa:
rallentare, ogni 27 giorni,
il ritmo di rotazione delle palette
dell'arricchimento dell'uranio,
per solo 15 minuti.
E voi direte: ma non
se ne sono accorti, gli ingegneri?
No, non se ne sono accorti
perché era impossibile
che se ne accorgessero,
poiché l'altra cosa
che faceva questo malware,
che è passato alla storia come Stuxnet,
era mandare in loop un video
che appunto faceva vedere
che tutto era sotto controllo.
Quindi voi capite che ci sono
diverse problematiche a riguardo.
Quello che è cambiato,
appunto nel corso della storia,
è che ci sono stati anche
degli altri Paesi, appunto.
Ad esempio la Russia,
spostandoci un po' più a nord,
ha utilizzato spesso,
nel corso della storia, l'Ucraina
come una sorta di "Test Field",
di campo di prova
delle proprie cyber armi.
Nel 2016, durante la Guerra di Crimea,
per diversi giorni e sotto Natale,
centinaia di migliaia
di persone, in Ucraina,
sono rimaste totalmente al buio,
nel black out più totale.
Non funzionavano i frigoriferi di casa,
non funzionavano le scuole.
E quello che ha salvato, in qualche modo,
l'Ucraina in quella fase
era che il suo livello di automazione,
come sistema Paese,
non era ancora così avanzato.
Perché la novità è
che nel ventunesimo secolo
essere tecnologicamente arretrati
può essere un vantaggio;
la disconnessione
è un vantaggio rispetto -
per una volta, possiamo dire
che sono le economie
più avanzate tecnologicamente
che sono più a rischio.
Facciamo un passo indietro.
Guerra Fredda.
Il mondo è governato da un acronimo,
l'acronimo è MAD -
Mutual Assured Destruction,
"Distruzione Mutuale Garantita".
Cosa vuol dire?
Era il motivo per cui nessuno,
né a Mosca né a Washington,
aveva il coraggio di schiacciare
il famoso pulsante rosso
delle testate nucleari,
perché chiunque sapeva
che sarebbe partito,
in direzione ostinata e contraria,
un attacco dall'altra parte,
in un'escalation che,
molti temevano all'epoca,
avrebbe forse portato, anche,
all'estinzione della specie umana
dalla faccia della Terra.
Cos'è cambiato, oggi?
Che oggi non è più -
Queste tecnologie estremamente distruttive
non sono più ad esclusivo appannaggio
delle grandi super potenze mondiali,
ma di tutta una serie di player, di attori
che sono entrati sul mercato,
anche alcuni molto piccoli.
Non so se conoscete questo film:
è un film del 2014,
che si intitola "The Interview"
in cui James Franco
caricaturizza Kim Jong-Un,
che è il presidente nordcoreano.
Come immaginerete, a Pyongyang
non l'hanno presa benissimo;
tant'è che nel giro di qualche giorno
il 70 per cento dei computer
aziendali di Sony,
che era la casa di distribuzione
del film americano,
è stato reso inutilizzabile:
per settimane i dipendenti della Sony
sono stati costretti a utilizzare
nuovamente carta e penna
invece che mandare delle e-mail.
E questo con un attacco
partito dalla piccola Nord Corea:
immaginate cosa può succedere,
ovviamente, sullo scenario mondiale.
Storicamente, però,
lo spionaggio è sempre stato
una questione sì di expertise,
ma anche di soldi:
si possono rubare i disegni
di una portaerei americana,
ma serve comunque poi avere
le finanze per poterla costruire.
Ecco: questo costo, di fatto,
è totalmente azzerato nel mondo digitale,
come abbiamo visto con l'attacco
degli Shadow Brokers,
che sono un po' l'equivalente di Banksy
applicato al mondo della cyber security,
ovvero sono una realtà appunto anonima
che è riuscita ad entrare
nella National Security Agency americana,
l'agenzia di sicurezza nazionale,
e di fatto a rubare
tutte le armi belliche cyber
più avanzate sulla faccia della Terra,
le più sofisticate;
e appunto, poi, metterle sul mercato.
Già, il mercato.
Il mercato è estremamente deregolamentato:
considerate che anche in guerra
ci sono delle regole.
Secondo la Convenzione di Ginevra,
non si possono bombardare,
ad esempio, degli ospedali civili,
anche durante una guerra.
Non si possono bombardare:
ma gli si può togliere
l'energia elettrica,
si possono rubare le cartelle cliniche.
Tutta questa parte digitale
non è assolutamente normata.
Ora, ci sono poi altri modi
di creare scompiglio
nel mondo del digitale, del cyber.
Ad esempio,
con l'Intelligenza Artificiale.
Questo cartello di stop
che noi vediamo con delle piccole pecette
quasi impercettibili all'occhio umano,
l'intelligenza artificiale che guida
le auto a guida autonoma
non lo interpreta come un segnale di stop,
ma come un cartello di velocità massima
a 45 chilometri orari.
Ora voi capite cosa questo,
in un mondo ormai prossimo,
dove la maggior parte,
o comunque buona parte delle macchine
andrà a guida autonoma,
cosa può creare a livello di scompiglio,
a livello di potenziali
incidenti a catena.
Il problema,
con l'Intelligenza Artificiale,
è che le modifiche per fregarla
sono inintelligibili agli umani.
Prendiamo quest'altro esempio,
questa simpatica foto di un gattino.
Le reti neurali
che stanno dietro agli algoritmi
delle Intelligenze Artificiali
effettivamente, come vedete,
tutte sono d'accordo
nell'etichettarlo come gattino.
Ma cosa succede se andiamo ad applicare
una piccola perturbazione avversaria
creata appunto da un cyber attacco?
Che questa rete che abbiamo aggiunto,
e che è, appunto, totalmente
invisibile all'occhio umano,
in realtà fa sì
che le reti neurali, in quel caso,
non lo riconoscano più come un gattino,
ma come uno struzzo.
Ora, voi capite questo cosa può portare,
ovviamente, su scala mondiale.
Dicevamo del mercato deregolamentato.
Uno degli esempi è quello
dei "zero days", dei giorni zero.
Sono vulnerabilità non conosciute,
che vengono scoperte da degli hacker
per la prima volta
e vengono spesso rivendute
alle stesse case madri
a cui sono state scoperte,
Ad esempio, Chaouki Bekrar,
che è un hacker molto famoso,
ha creato qualche anno fa
un'azienda che si chiama Zerodium,
e che ha pubblicato, in maniera
direi piuttosto sfacciata, online
un listino prezzi,
organizzato tra l'altro
in maniera molto gradevole
come una tavola periodica degli elementi,
dove per ogni singola vulnerabilità
viene pagato come premio,
all'hacker che l'ha trovata -
ad esempio, per WhatsApp
un milione di dollari;
per una vulnerabilità
sconosciuta su iPhone
fino a due milioni di dollari.
Quindi, capite che è un settore
piuttosto redditizio.
Che sia redditizio ce ne siamo accorti
anche dagli attacchi ransomware,
che sono degli attacchi
in cui si entra dentro un sistema,
si crittografano tutti i dati,
e poi si chiede un riscatto,
un ransom appunto,
per ridare indietro la chiave,
per riavere i propri dati indietro.
In media, un attacco di questo genere
frutta a chi lo perpetra
circa tre milioni di dollari.
E i target possono essere:
università, Comuni, Regioni,
aziende private, condotte del gas -
come è stato in America, recentemente.
E non sempre è facile capire
chi sono i buoni e chi sono i cattivi.
Perché, ad esempio,
le aziende che fanno
questi attacchi di ransomware
in alcuni casi hanno dei principi etici:
per cui, ad esempio,
non attaccano gli ospedali
o non attaccano organizzazioni
non governative;
e danno, in alcuni casi,
addirittura parte
dei loro guadagni in beneficenza.
Quindi un'altra tipologia
di potenziali attacchi, ad esempio,
è quello del phishing.
Il phishing è un'attività,
anche qui malevola e fraudolenta,
che ad esempio vi manda dei messaggi
dove ci si finge ad esempio
i vostri sistemi bancari
e vi si chiedono le vostre credenziali
per entrare e ovviamente poter rubare
le vostre finanze o altre cose,
E considerate che questa
tipologia di attacchi
non riguardano solo
gli analfabeti funzionali,
o gli analfabeti digitali.
Una carta di credito su due,
negli Stati Uniti, è stata clonata;
e non solo quella della zia Maria,
anche quella di Barack Obama.
Ora noi siamo consapevoli
di essere davanti solo alla punta
della punta dell'iceberg.
Anche perché la prima regola,
nel mondo degli hacker, è:
mai parlare di hacking.
Ma c'è un problema strutturale, direi,
all'interno dei grandi centri
di innovazione,
ad esempio in Silicon Valley.
Uno dei motti di Mark Zuckerberg,
prima del recente turnaround
verso il mondo del metaverso,
è: "move fast and break things",
muoviti veloce e rompi le cose,
Il contrario di quello
che un buon consulente
di cybersecurity ti consiglierebbe;
il contrario, probabilmente, di quello
che anche il buon senso suggerirebbe.
Il risultato?
Mezzo miliardo di account di Facebook
sono stati hackerati.
Ora, mi rendo conto
che sia difficile fare previsioni -
soprattutto sul futuro,
come diceva il fisico danese Niels Bohr -
ma come ad esempio testimoniano
delle frasi come questa:
"Nessuno avrà mai bisogno di più di 637
kilobyte di memoria in un computer."
Una frase pronunciata
esattamente quarant'anni fa
da un signore che peraltro, poi,
prima di fare soldi con i vaccini
qualche computer l'avrebbe poi venduto,
il signor Bill Gates.
Ma nonostante questo,
mi sento comunque di fare una scommessa
perché è una scommessa
veramente molto facile.
Gli attacchi aumenteranno,
e aumenteranno in maniera esponenziale.
Banalmente, perché siamo
nell'era dell'IOT,
l'Internet of Things,
l'Internet delle cose,
che nel mondo cyber security
è conosciuta anche come
"Internet of Threats", delle minacce.
Ora dopo questo piccolo excursus
avrete capito che non c'è poi
così tanto da preoccuparsi:
c'è proprio da terrorizzarsi.
Per cui, veniamo forse alla parte
che vi interessa di più in questa fase,
il messaggio più di speranza:
come ci proteggiamo?
Qua dobbiamo distinguere
tra tre categorie:
le aziende, i sistemi Paese
e i singoli individui.
Per le aziende, un buon modo è partire
da quella che è nota come
"assunzione di compromissione":
"Build it like it's Broken",
costruiscilo come se fosse già bucato.
Siccome è molto probabile, appunto,
che qualcuno entri nei vostri sistemi,
una maniera saggia di costruirli
è di creare dei compartimenti stagni
oltre cui non si riesca ad andare
in eventuali attacchi.
Se dovete entrare in un sottomarino,
e sapete che prima o poi
questo sottomarino
farà entrare dell'acqua,
è bene isolare quella parte
e mettere in sicurezza,
ovviamente, l'equipaggio.
Per i sistemi Paese,
è più una questione di investimenti
e di volontà politica.
Parlavamo prima della
Convenzione di Ginevra:
la Convenzione di Ginevra
è stata siglata nel 1864,
ha più di 150 anni.
Aggiornarla ad oggi,
in un'era in cui siamo connessi
per cinque-sei ore al giorno,
non è solo un nostro diritto,
è un nostro preciso dovere nei confronti
delle prossime generazioni.
Così come è un nostro dovere,
un gesto di civiltà necessario,
non lasciare il famoso difensore
da solo contro i 100 attaccanti.
E veniamo infine, al piano personale.
Ricordatevi, intanto,
questo consiglio molto spicciolo
che si rifà a un acronimo:
2FA, autenticazione a due fattori.
Che è quello che vi permette di verificare
che effettivamente,
quello che sta entrando in questo momento,
dal vostro computer di casa
dentro al vostro home banking,
siete effettivamente voi
tramite un doppio controllo,
un doppio check su un altro dispositivo,
banalmente sul vostro cellulare.
Poi mi rendo conto che sia difficile,
nel ventunesimo secolo,
consigliarvi di digitalizzarvi meno;
ma almeno, cerchiamo
di digitalizzarci meglio,
o meglio con più consapevolezza.
Vale per l'utilizzo
della Rete in generale,
anche perché, per la prima volta
nel corso della storia dell'umanità,
non solo i nostri sistemi,
ma la nostra stessa mente
è diventata hackerabile,
come sostiene lo storico israeliano
Yuval Noah Harari.
E qui non parlo, guardate,
di sonde cerebrali alla Elon Musk,
o di Neuralink.
Parlo di una cosa molto più spicciola:
la nostra libertà di pensiero.
Quindi, qui dimenticatevi il ragazzino
con la felpa con cappuccio
e concentriamoci su quello
che invece potrebbe essere
veramente il vero colpevole,
ovvero i sistemi degli algoritmi.
Secondo uno studio dell'Università
di Cambridge del 2015,
con 70 like un algoritmo
vi conosce meglio di un vostro amico.
Se i like salgono a 300,
l'algoritmo vi conosce
meglio del vostro partner,
di vostra moglie, del vostro marito.
Per cui, la domanda che dovete farvi è:
quanti like sono necessari all'algoritmo
per conoscerci meglio di noi stessi?
Se state cliccando su un'immagine
di un uomo a torso nudo in una pubblicità,
piuttosto che una donna,
state dando informazioni all'algoritmo
che forse neanche voi sapete di sapere,
o in qualche modo accettate di sapere.
E questo vale per le nostre
preferenze sessuali,
ma anche per altre inclinazioni
che sono coperte in ogni caso
da bias, da nostri pregiudizi.
Per cui, e qui chiudo,
oltre alle informazioni
che rischiano di essere rubate,
che sono il mestiere effettivamente
che faccio della cyber security,
state molto attenti alle informazioni
che deliberatamente scegliete
di condividere,
e di regalare agli algoritmi.
Perché in un'era in cui
non solo i nostri possedimenti,
ma la nostra stessa identità,
non è mai stata così digitale,
difendere i nostri dati online
significa, in ultima istanza,
difendere chi siamo.
Grazie.
(Applausi)